a 42 here in 1955 Johnny Cash wrote and
recorded a song that will become a
worldwide hit Folsom Prison Blues in
1887 van gock admitted himself to a
mental asylum in southern France and
spent his time painting first he
beautiful pieces of arts that are almost
priceless today in 1603 Shakespeare
wrote a fellow one of his many
masterpieces these masters of the art
created one-of-a-kind originals using
nothing but the contents of their own
brains as though their works were like
gifts from the heavens the only problem
is that this is also crap all the
aforementioned creations were stolen and
I'll tell you exactly how and why in a
few seconds but first a quick word about
our sponsor raid shadow legends for
those who don't know raid shadow legends
is a brand-new collection RPG game that
is taking the mobile gaming landscape by
storm it has great graphics strategic
gameplay huge boss fights an amazing
storyline and over 400 champions for you
to collect and personally customized my
favorite champion is this big heavy dude
Sir Nicholas because well he looks like
Santa with a sword and he's got freaking
antlers on his back it's got it all the
game is free-to-play you can enjoy PvP
battles at arena PvE in dungeons and
cool huge boss fights personally I think
the game is amazing but don't just take
my word for it with 200 thousand reviews
raid has almost a perfect score on the
Play Store there is a new awesome
loyalty program where you'll get a new
daily login reward for the first 90 days
in the game so what are you waiting for
go to the video description click on my
special link and you'll instantly get
50,000 silver and a free epic champion
as part of the new player program to
start your journey good luck and I'll
see you there so you're a Johnny Cash
fer aren't we all
well he did steal Folsom Prison Blues
almost word-for-word from a song
released two years earlier by another
American composer Gordon Jenkins his
song was called Crescent City blues and
if you listen to it on another tab of
course then you'll notice that the
melody and more than half the words are
identical to Folsom Prison Blues Cash
tried to get away with his forgery - he
didn't credit Jenkins anywhere on the
record which sold many thousands more
copies than the original the cash was
later sued after his version became a
worldwide hit the lawsuit cost him
$75,000 van got 30 masterpieces were all
precise replicas and 30 artworks by over
artists although I am being a slight bit
unfair on the matte Dutchman he actually
admitted that these were all copies at
the time in fact that was his intention
to copy as closely as possible or in his
own way works that he admired although
it is still interesting to learn that
even a master such as van gock needed to
copy now and then for inspiration and
Shakespeare well he stole a lot of his
work a fellow was a story borrowed from
a previous Italian novelist Giovanni
Cynthia Hamlet was stolen from 12th
century Danish writer sack so dramatic
as' and Romeo and Juliet yes that was
stolen - from a poem written by Alpha
Brook in 1562
the poem was even called the tragical
history of Romeo and Juliet but am i
angry that these legends of the Arts the
Titans of creativity have been lying to
us
hell no stealing other people's work was
one of the best things that they ever
did these people may have mixed their
treasure but who cares when they did
such wonderful things with the booty
Crescent City Blues sounds great but
Folsom Prison Blues sold better because
well let's be honest it's a hell of a
lot catchy and has a higher production
value than the original song Shakespeare
arguably did greater things with the
material on he copy
than anyone else in history he
transformed the stories he stole into
truly beautiful creations that elevated
the English language to a godly level
permanently enriching the tapestry of
mankind in the process the fact that
Shakespeare stole these stories doesn't
disparage his work in the slightest he
was still a literary genius and
potentially no one else could have given
these existing tales such a breath of
brilliant new life if he had copied the
stories word-for-word then that's a
whole different ballgame and that's not
okay but truthfully lots of bigwigs will
hate me for saying this but copyright
theft doesn't matter it's what you do
with it that counts
these free examples are just a tip of
the iceberg when it comes to famous
works that are actually copies in fact I
would argue that the majority of all
creative works you know today books
music film etc are copied from someone
who came earlier if this is true then it
begs to question is any idea truly
original well no there was a point in
history when truly original ideas were
still possible but such a rare
phenomenon has not existed for at least
2,000 years and probably not since
humans began building large
interconnected civilizations your brain
is a collection of millions of memories
collected over your entire life whenever
you have an idea you won't always aware
of it but your subconscious borrows
little bits of these memories and
combines them to imagine something new
you cook derive these new ideas from
bits of hundreds of different memories
or just three individual memories but
you can't avoid it this is how the human
brain works the inception of a 100%
unique idea is not possible because the
brain always has to draw on prior
knowledge from somewhere to frustrate
matters even further in most creative
fields there are actually a very limited
amount of possibilities that can be
realized
which makes repeats or at least very
close duplicate
inevitable take for example a novel you
would think that there are limitless
possibilities for writing fiction but
not quite at least that's not what
Christopher broker thought he postulated
that there are only seven possible plots
and all works of fiction ever written
fall into one of them they are
overcoming the monster think Beowulf war
of the worlds' James Bond rags to riches
Cinderella
Jane Eyre Great Expectations the quest
the Lord of the Rings
the pilgrims progress voyage and return
Alice in Wonderland's Peter rabbit's
gone with the wind
comedy much ado about nothing Twelfth
Night tragedy Macbeth
Romeo and Juliet rebirth a Christmas
carol Beauty and the Beast
you can go round and round in your mind
all day conjuring up wild story lines up
may not quite fit into one of those
seven and if you do you'll probably end
up down some truly dark and stupid
destinations such as this tale and I
came up with about a man who grows a
third nipple and has to take up
underwater basket-weaving to make enough
money to have it removed but then you
realize that that's just an effin
bizarre example of the quest or possibly
overcoming the monster depending on how
you look at it and even within these
categories you often find that so many
acclaimed stories are the same we've hit
the human experience there are only
finite things that's a character in a
book can actually do because of this
every now and then a very odd phenomenon
occurs films are released by completely
unrelated and
independent studios that have identical
plots and neither was aware of the other
films existence until after their
release this is so eerily common that it
has been given a name twin films for
example in 1986 Top Gun was really
and so was a remarkably similar but
spectacularly less successful film
called ayan Eagle in 1998 there was ants
under books life in 1999 there was the
mummy and tail of the mummy in 2006
there was The Illusionist and the
prestige these are just a few examples
of many some twin films have been
attributed to espionage of in the film
industry what many of us are a pure
coincidence after all over 2500 films
are released each year but it could also
be due to the fact that there are only a
limited amount of possible storylines
that can be altered sure but the core
story will remain the same even when you
are absolutely certain that your idea is
entirely original
you may actually be suffering from a
case of Krypton easier this is when you
recall a memory you had forgotten and
you mistakenly think that it's an
original idea that you just generated
but in reality the joke or concept for a
book film etc is something you heard or
saw a long time ago that just got buried
deep in the recesses of your mind next
to lots of other stuff that you hope
never resurfaces as you can imagine
Krypton easier can get you in trouble if
you are adamant that your idea is
original but it turns out to us to be
plagiarized and Krypton easia has come
for many well-known people when the
American writer Helen Keller was 11 she
wrote a short story called
the frost king well later in her life it
was discovered that the entire thing was
plagiarized from a fairy tale called
frost fairies Helen Keller had no idea
she was committing plagiarism at the
time she was suffering from Krypton
easier but she later recalled that she
had in fact read Frost fairies for years
before she wrote the frost King she got
into trouble and her name was dragged
through the mud by the papers the event
left Keller a nervous wreck and she
would never write fiction again so if
having an original idea is almost
impossible
and if you do then it's probably just
Krypton easier anyway then it begs to
question should we all be committing
plagiarism and just hoping to get away
with it or should we go the other way
and all put paper bags over our heads
and sit in the corner shaking because
we're afraid that if we utter a single
word we could be breaking the law
well there is actually a happy medium
and it's what about 99% of us do when we
want to create a great piece of honest
creative work plagiarism is obviously
morally wrong plagiarism is taking
someone else's work or concept and
passing it off as your own with little
to no changes to its content I would
personally abhor anyone who practices
plagiarism and hopes to get away with it
but there isn't anything inherently
wrong with using one or more pieces of
other people's work as heavy inspiration
so long as you add value when true
originality isn't possible and it seldom
is then greatness can only be achieved
by adding value few of Shakespeare's
works are genuinely original but he
achieved greatness
time after time by taking already
successful stories and rewriting them
using astonishing language to elevate
them to a new level that the original
writer could never actually achieve
imagine if Shakespeare had to come up
with a truly original storyline each
time he wanted to write a new play he
would have far less time to focus on
carefully crafting beautiful lines and
probably won't have written nearly as
many plays for future generations to
enjoy and love using other people's work
as a base allows one to not get caught
in a hopeless black hole of imagination
trying to fathom some immaculate
conception of an original idea that will
likely never come by by passing this
step and building upon the work of
others you can get a head start and
focus on adding significant value to
truly make it into a unique piece that
may actually improve upon the original
because when you think about it taking
over people's stuff and building upon it
is literally am
civilization was built and it's why we
are where we are today forget about
whether what you are working on has been
done a hundred times before and focus on
what you personally can add to it that
nobody else can do this authentically
and with passion and you will create
something amazing in doing so you will
not be alone the best musicians of the
past century have taken heavy
inspiration from the great classical
composers that laid the groundwork for
them and what is Star Wars have not an
amalgamation of spaghetti westerns
samurai films and footages Spitfire
dogfights during World War two
all set in space instead of being
intimidated by all the great work that
has come before you let it instead
inspire you and there is no limit to
what you could achieve thanks for
watching